[Music]
good afternoon everybody thank you for
coming to my session I really hope I can
teach you something new in the next 45
minutes the title of the session is it's
a bit large
I don't like anymore I kinda want to
change it and it's a security
practitioners guide to best practice GTP
security and I'm not gonna be everything
to everybody so I'm probably going to
disappoint everybody in this room but
hopefully I can teach you at least maybe
one thing new that you can take away and
implement today so my name is Tom salmon
and I'm a customer engineer in Google
Cloud I'm based in London and I
primarily work with financial service
customers primarily in banking I joined
Google 18 months ago before that I
worked in security doing engineering
design architecture and consulting
mostly building security operation
centers my aim here today is to share
with you what I've learned from my
customers what they've told me
conversations we've had together and
where I think there's maybe gaps in
people's knowledge that I think I can
hopefully upskill you so what we are and
aren't going to do today we will cover
the common questions I've had from my
customers the areas of common
misunderstanding where we spend time
going over things that can be fairly
fundamental but sometimes people get
wrong we're going to look at how we take
lots of different services and bundle
them into secure solutions we're not
going to cover everything in the DCP
platform we're gonna cover a core number
of services and they're mostly focused
around infrastructure and by that we're
going to be looking at permissions and
logging and security and how that cuts
across every service we have rather than
digging into specifics around App Engine
or bigquery we won't talk about roadmap
there's no announcements here today we
won't talk about third-party solutions
I'm not going to talk about other
vendors you can work with and we won't
get really deep into networking or
encryption there's a huge amount of
sessions going on next I thought I'd
leave that to the experts and there's an
assumption this session is set under and
that is that you trust Google Cloud is
secure so my customers tell me
we trust you Google we believe your
platform security is good enough for us
what we want to do
is build solutions on top of it the
secure to our needs if you don't agree
with that statement that's fine
security specialists and customer
injures on myself a happy to meet with
you and discuss the security of the
platform but everything we talked about
today is on top of GCP cool so there's
three things in my agenda roughly we're
going to talk about control control is
around access control it's around I am
it's around roles and service accounts
and granting people access to resources
what are the best practices and how do
you do that securely and how would an
enterprise do that we'll go and look at
visibility how do you monitor what's
happening how do you validate that the
controls and permissions that you put in
place are actually giving you the
controls you think they're giving you
and then we're going to talk about how
we wrap up some services into solutions
and solve some common problems and my
customers have brought to me so controls
the first thing we have to talk about is
I am identity an Access Management it's
fundamental to everything that happens
on Google cloud platform and in any
cloud and the thing that took awhile for
some of my customers to twig
is that it's very centralized if you
look at GCP everything is integrated
with I am you can assign a role to a
user and suddenly they might access have
access to a ton of resources they didn't
have before whereas in traditional
on-premise environments they found that
actually it might be four or five or six
different teams the team that manages
the firewall rules opening a pool the
team that managed the servers controls
to allow you and the team that then
grabs you permissions to the right
Active Directory access to it it's a
whole bunch of people and actually it's
a bit higher risk having everything
control through I am because you can
more easily give people the wrong access
so you really need to put a lot more
focus into doing it right and making
sure that you're locking it down a lot
more than you would necessarily
on-premise so what we're going to look
at is who can access what resources
which sounds pretty simple but there's
lots of questions that come out of this
such as how do you figure out what
resources they should be accessing and
as she who can access those resources is
a pretty hard question to answer most of
the time
the very first piece of advice I'll give
you is all of your access should be
based around groups if a user is
directly given permission to resources
then you have a significant burden in
monitoring and management and trying to
understand who can access what I would
actually say you should be actively
scanning for and looking for any usage
of identity controls that rely on the
individual accessing any resource
everything through a group allows you to
put in proper GML processes and correct
monitoring and it's much easier to
manage as well and I see this mistake
being made at the start of
implementations when people are starting
to work with Google cloud they go oh
we'll just we'll have this one person
accessing this rules and these couple of
people can have this project over here
it's best to start strong and stick with
it consistently as you scale and grow
your use of the platform when you're six
or twelve months down the road it can be
hard to back out so just a really simple
example of a group that some of my
customers might use would be global sec
ops admins there's an two roles below it
there are security admins and their log
viewers you can basically figure out
what they do based on the name of the
group so it's self describing so if you
are reviewing an alert or a log that
contains the group name you can kind of
figure out what access they have based
on that group name and secondly
understanding folder structures and how
they fit into the resource hierarchy is
pretty important so just to go over this
again for people that aren't aware at
the very top you have your organization
there's one organization at your company
below it you have projects sorry below
it you have folders many folders and
hierarchies below that you have projects
and then those projects have resources
inside of them the best way to map it up
in my opinion and I found with most of
my customers is to map your folder
hierarchy to your company layout and
structure and by that I mean separate
here into different countries different
working groups different teams and doing
the logical separation and using folders
as many times as you need to to have
that clean separation because when you
apply constraints and policies at an
organization level and they trickle down
you can then apply it to a folder
further down the chain and that will
trickle down as
another resultant thing that I found is
that the folder hierarchy isn't always
apparent so for example if you're
looking at an access control list if
you're looking at a log it will come
with a project name but it's not always
obvious to many people where does that
projects it in the folder hierarchy so
simply just expand it out into the
project name structure it as
organization name I recommend you always
prefix with your organization name at
the start and then expand out the folder
tree in the project name make use of
long project names it's absolutely fine
simple example Acme Corp have a sales
organization there's an application
running inside of it that provides
insight around what their clients are
doing and this is the production version
of that application it's self describing
it's easy to understand and it's easy to
debug where it sits in the folder tree
without having to go to someone that can
actually see it and give you that
information you're trying to lower the
burden and the admin overhead so service
accounts are something that I didn't
really know that much about and I
assumed I kind of knew how they worked
until I started writing this
presentation and I had it completely
wrong and the real key advice that I had
from one of the security PM's was you
need to think of security counts as
service counts sorry as both a resource
and an identity there's two perspectives
you need to be really aware of them so
when we think about a resource a
resource has controls as to who can
access that resource so in this case
let's say you've created a service
account you want to limit who can use
that service account so this simple
diagram shows you there's a user called
Alice and she'd like to start a virtual
machine she'd like to start that using a
particular service account that's been
generated so she needs a role that
allows her service account user to use
that service account so she has a
constraint on being able to access it
normally that list of people of service
account users should be pretty small and
pretty focused and you should be
reviewing who has that access because as
soon as you actually start using the
service account and you start up that
instance using the service account it
flips over and it becomes an identity
then the identity
has access to resources on the other
side so that's in having permissions and
roles as to kind of access a Google
Cloud Storage bucket can I access a
spanner database can it create some
credentials elsewhere so what this means
is that a user who has service account
user permissions can then actually
access all the resources that service
account can access as well not
necessarily directly but actually
through that service account they can
access area at the house and that can
really greatly increase the scope of
access that individual user has through
that one role so simple tips things that
have caught me out before and caught out
my customers have a naming convention
and one of the things I say for a naming
convention is actually saying it's a
service account in the name if you look
at a log or a pull or an add call it
just looks like an email address is it a
person or is it a service account just
put in front SVC or essay or service to
obviously delineate this is a service
account the display name is a longer
name a number of my customers have found
putting the particular roles given for a
service account in the display name also
makes it easier to figure out what it
does and what it should access and
actually how much permission does that
have to access other resources being
verbose and repeating yourself isn't
really a problem so then the question
becomes how many service accounts do we
need and the answer is it depends which
is the worst answer you can give to
anyone so generally as a rule of thumb
what I'm looking at is how many roles
are given to a particular service
account we generally say the each of
your applications or services should
have a service account if you're then
giving it many roles 5 10 15 or 20 it's
probably a hint you should be
refactoring the application if you can
control it or trying to decompose it
into multiple items so what you have to
think about here is if someone picked up
that service account and they took it
away and they used it later on it can be
hard to monitor how a service account is
being used and if there's multiple
service accounts being used in multiple
places and it's that one account can
access 10 different resources then
that's a concentration rest that you
should be looking at a lot more closely
and don't rely on the default service
accounts so whenever you create a new
project and you spin up a compute engine
API it will create you a default service
account that's really useful for testing
and development we do not guarantee the
functionality of that service account
the roles and scopes it might have we
also don't guarantee it might exist in
the future whether we create that
default service account or not if
anything today relies on the default
service account you should immediately
stop using it and transition to custom
service accounts that you can control
because there may be a breaking change
so something actually learn on Monday
this week and added this slide on
Tuesday was trying to answer the
question of who can access what so which
user can access this pick the resource
or who could delete this virtual machine
is a really hard question to answer and
there's a great piece of software called
for SETI for SETI is open source
software originally developed by Google
cloud that we use to monitor our
policies and we need to mount those
questions ourselves it's pretty simple
and how it works we do an inventory we
take a list of all the users we take a
list of all the groups we fake list of
all the roles we take list of all the
resources we build a model on top of it
and then you can query that model and
you can directly ask it who could delete
this virtual machine for this user what
can they access who has service account
user permissions it's a really quick way
to get answers to those questions it's
freely available open-source software
online I'd highly recommend you review
that was control and that was really
centered around Identity and Access
Management and as you'll see as we go
through this everything builds on top of
it when you're looking at cloud security
so for visibility we're going to talk a
lot around logging trying to understand
which users are actually using those
permissions and who is doing what in the
operational perspective the main tool
here is stack driver
stack driver has a ton of functionality
it's a fantastic platform that does a
million things really well there's some
great announcements that next this week
is what it does
but we're going to talk about a
subsection of it stackdriver logging so
stackdriver monitoring is generally for
the operations teams it's asking you how
much CPU usage is on this particular
machine
how much latency is on this particular
load balancer stacked over logging takes
generally human readable log syntax form
or JSON format passes them and makes
them available for developers debugging
an application and typically security
teams who want to look at what's changed
how did it change and how does that
affect me so on GCP there's a number of
different logging platforms and a number
of different locusts that are produced
the two we're going to read talk about
here are admin activity logs and data
access logs adament activity logs are on
by default and you can't turn them off
so whenever you make a change through
the admin console whenever you run into
you cloud command whenever you do
something that changes your platform in
any way that's logged for you and you
can't stop that
that's good thing and it's free it's
baked into the costume what's also
available is data access logging so data
access logging looks on top of the
platform and says well insight your
applications we can log what happens an
example cloud sequel if I go and create
a cloud sequel cluster and create some
nodes that will be logged through the
admin activity logs if I actually send a
query to my cloud sequel database that
can be logged inside the data access
logs we can log if it's a read query we
can log if it's a change if it says
modify or a delete and this is fairly
consistent across most of our products
but it's not enabled by default and it
can produce a huge amount of locks you
need to be really aware of how much this
can produce I'm going to talk in a
second about reducing that volume to a
manageable quantity so the first thing
to say is you need different permissions
to access the data access logs because
they're inherently more sensitive
because they contain data access and
data change so the default logging
permission you're going to give to your
Ops teams and developers is logging data
viewer they can view the locks
to get data access logging access you
need logging dot private log viewer I'm
just in the name it's a lot more private
information it should be a much smaller
subset of people because they're looking
at actually this data access and who's
changing the data access so a quick
example of how you can turn this on and
how you can configure it you can do it
through a GUI or you can do it through
g-cloud and you can configure this an
organizational level and speed it down
the hierarchy or you can do it on a per
project basis so in this example we're
doing it for one particular project so
I'm pulling out that I am policy for my
project 1 2 3 I didn't follow my own
naming convention advice we feed into a
Yammer file and then we modify it and we
disap end at the bottom the audit
configuration and all we're saying is
we're gonna for every service enable
data read data right and also admin read
so admin reads every time you run a read
command through g-cloud so if you list
all the virtual machine instances you
have that's an admin read if you create
a virtual machine doesn't have been
change in an app been right so simply we
change the Yammer file we write it back
in and that project will now produce
logs for all the data read and all the
data write for every single service you
have and now is a huge amount of
information it could be good could be
bad tell you what you want to monitor
typically you want to exclude certain
services so building on this example
we're going to show you how you can pull
out say for cloud sequel how do we
remove one particular service account
from logging those data access locks so
the use case here is you have an
application that's serving an API and
you've written it in Python it's serving
your users behind the scenes as a cloud
sequel database and that cloud sequel
database is the primary storage system
lots of reads lots of writes coming
through your application is running
under the service account you created
your custom service account actually
this is the default service account I
should have changed that and what you
want to say is let's exempt this
particular service account for cloud
sequel from data read and data right so
what you're left with is any data access
not by the production's
his account running your application so
it means that you'll get access and logs
every time a human or a different
service tries to access or change data
in that database so instantly that's
kind of interesting saying well my DBA
has now changed something in a
production database or an engineer is
logged in and run some queries against
it that isn't the typical flow that we'd
expect that's worth monitoring you can
also do this through the GUI so through
the I am console you can go in you can
turn on the default audit logs you can
turn on the day to read and write logs
you can choose particular services you
can build the exemptions I'd recommend
this for testing to figure out how many
logs does it produce it's a good way to
figure out actually is it a couple of
Meg's or a couple of gigs or a couple of
terabytes we're dealing with here but
normally you want to do is
programmatically most of the time
particularly dealing with exceptions
when you're looking at data access
logging you should be doing on a
case-by-case basis most of the time data
I'm sorry admin read logs could be
turned on across the platform again be
aware of how much volume it can produce
so another challenge my customers
brought to me was by default logs and
GCP lived within the project that
created in if you're an enterprise you
could well have hundreds of thousands of
different projects created in many
different countries and that becomes an
ab an overhead having to go to every
single project to look at the logs
inside of it and it stops you
correlating them together and looking
for interesting patterns across your
environment so with stackdriver
we can do aggregated log exporting so
simply we can take the logs from lots of
different member projects put them
through some filters so the filters
could be to only forward on particular
services particularly users particular
accounts you could sample it down so you
say just send 10% of it that's only
interesting to me and then there's three
different sources you can send it to
sorry destinations there's cloud storage
so you can write it just as plain text
files commonly this is done for
compliance we need to store this for
three years five years seven years as
cheap as possible so it's available if
we did need to do any investigation down
the line you can send it to bigquery so
that you can run sequel queries against
it and do some analysis and
pretty common I'll talk to you about an
example of that in a minute you can also
send it to pub/sub and pub/sub is
typically where third party platforms
integrate so tools like Splunk have
connectors that read from pops up to
take those logs out the other side so
let's assume that all of your projects
are sending their logs to one particular
cloud storage bucket you want to do your
archiving compliance and make them stay
there for seven years there's a couple
of things that I'd recommend to make
sure those logs are sound and safe and
secure the first thing is turning on
object versioning on the Google Cloud
Storage bucket the reason for that is
that when you turn on object versioning
you can't actually delete files anymore
you can run the delete command
but that files never delete it the
reference to it says it's gone but the
file is still there if someone
accidentally changed the file we keep
all the previous versions as well so you
never actually lose anything as long as
that's turned on and of course this
bucket you'll lock down the permissions
on it the project it's running in your
lock down the access to this project as
well and there's another level you can
apply webbing put controls on the
project itself so you can apply
something called a lien which
essentially says you can't delete this
project it's really simple to apply and
it's just another level of control
against accidental deletion or
potentially malicious deletion it's a
really simple command it's done by
resource manager you do it on a per
project basis and I highly recommend
doing this for all your production
projects for although your applications
are running anything that just doesn't
need to be deleted accidentally I'd
recommend turning this flag on all that
happens is if you run a command to
delete the project it comes back with an
error saying no that can't be done and
you can give a specific reason as to why
that can't be done pretty wouldn't call
a super-secret logs but I might call it
something a bit more generic just in
case but I only stop you from both
malicious and accidental deletions
trying to make sure your logs are safe
and sound cool so I want to talk about
about security solutions and bi
solutions I mean combining lots of
different elements together to solve
common challenges and my customers had
the first and pretty most common
verse Asian I have with people is how do
I run my applications securely so I
haven't line of business at a business
application it's HR application or a
finance application and it's out there
and our users should be able to access
this from the corporate environment
really where we want to get them to is
the beyond court model if you're not
familiar with beyond Corp I highly
recommend doing some research into it or
attending the session that we have
running at the moment or watching the
replay beyond Corp is talking about
beyond the corporate network how can we
have all of our projects and
applications running in a way that
people can access it from anywhere
without being behind a particular IP
address without having to dial up VPN
into the office and access it from
trusted IP ranges which doesn't work at
scale so when we start to take people on
the journey towards a beyond corpse
style model the first thing that comes
up is VPNs
people don't live EP ends and it's
having the constraint around people
either remotely accessing in or dealing
with just the admin overhead of managing
it how can we start to build
applications that take advantage of
Google scale so you can take advantage
of our denial of service protection so
you can deal with our scale or
networking without having a bottleneck
in place so there's three components
we're gonna put together the first one
is cloud armor and that's protecting the
edge so limiting who and how they can
access we're going to talk about
identity or web proxy so we can make
sure that only users that are
authenticated and authorized to access
the application can access the
application and then we can talk about
VPC firewall so how do you actually
restrict the ports and protocols that
can communicate with the application
you're running so in a really simplified
example it looks a little bit like this
so this is kind of step one of the
journey so let's imagine you have your
employee in your San Francisco office
and the external IP address from that
office is 1.2.3.4 to make life easy for
everyone the first thing that would
happen with that traffic is hopefully
we'll get routed over to the Google
cloud platform the first place it meets
is our edge proxies or edge pops and
cloud armor sits on top of them is a
bolt-on service so everything we're
talking about here
identity we're proxy and cloud armor raw
eyes on not changing your architecture
we're not telling you to install a VM
and push your traffic through it we're
trying to layer the capabilities onto
your existing design and the existing
capabilities we have today we don't
believe you should change your
application to get more security so the
first thing I'm going to do is you just
don't do simple white listing and black
listing through cloud armor we're just
going to allow connections from
particular IP addresses in this case
we'll just do it for your corporate
ranges so 1.2.3.4 can connect through
and that will allow it to initiate a TLS
session using Google networking
technologies to HTTPS load balancer
serving your particular application in
your particular project so then we're
going to add on identity aware proxy
identity where proxy is actually the
service that we released that's as close
to beyond Corp as we have internally at
Google as possible and it's a great
roadmap for identity web proxy is really
coming on leaps and bounds the concept
is this you should provide network based
authentication and network restriction
based on the identity of the user so if
I'm an employee I know working HR the
ideal scenario is the only network
services I can ever talk to are those
which relate to my job and my function
in HR there might be tens or hundreds of
thousands of applications that are
running out there but normally you can
ping them you can talk to them you're
free can't log into it that's a very
wide net that you could touch identity
web proxy looks at your user credentials
looks at the roles and the groups that
you're associated with you can integrate
it because it's backed off by cloud
identity so you can use Active Directory
Federation services you can use
two-factor authentication as single
sign-on and then it says well actually
you can't get through this load balancer
you can't get through this proxy unless
your job role and function and group is
correct so it means actually the attack
service is significantly reduced because
no longer does any employee have network
connectivity to all the applications
that are out there you're no longer
reliant on the application orphaned
casing and authorizing those services
because as we all know if there's a
particular vulnerability in some part of
the stack in some middleware messaging
platform
that any of those desktops if they were
compromised are going to sweep the
network try and find one particular
application service environment that has
that vulnerability and then they have a
way into your network with this you've
suddenly restricted that down to a small
subset of your application servers that
are only hosting the services they
should be able to access so let's assume
they pass through your identity web
proxy and they're allowed to access this
service next up again we're going to use
cloud armor so what cloud armor can do
is that now we know that this is a
trusted user and it's a HTTP the load
balancer we can inspect with contents of
the packet so we can do some simple
sequel injection and checking we can
look for cross-site scripting we can
just check the packets seen with the
right size and shape and volume and talk
conform to standards if that looks good
well then pass it through to the service
on the backend in this instance we use
compute engine so it's running a simple
infrastructure as a service could be
coupie now these engine could be App
Engine flexible which in turn will have
the VPC firewalls and those VPC
firewalls will allow you to restrict
ports and protocols at a networking
level so the next question I normally
get from people is okay so like so she
and we're trying to move away from IP
whitelisting and blacklisting we want to
promote employee mobility so people can
work from home we're not having to get
them to dial up to our remote office
range and connect through there but we
only want be able to access it from the
US or if they're in the UK only in the
UK so again cloud armor has
functionality you can write a simple
rule that says we're going to let you in
if the origin your traffic comes from
this or these particular countries or on
the flipside we don't like these
particular countries for you to come
from so this is kind of step two on the
journey you're removing the hard Ivy
white listing and saying right well
actually now my employees I know that
working in the United States which is
better for me they're going through and
we validate from the packets we know
that they're doing the right job
function we know that using two-factor
authentication and finally they can
actually access the application services
we're running I generally find talking
my customers that's a high level of
security than ever be able to build with
some kind of DMZ they've had for last 15
years
and this is all scalable Google
technology you're not relying on a
single point of failure you're not
relying on managing particular
traditional technologies another thing
you can do now is you can enforce
standards around SSL and TLS so attach
to the HTTPS load balancer that we're
running you can simply state the ciphers
that you're allowed and the versions of
TLS that you all accept for clients to
connect to it so you can enforce a
minimum of TLS 1.2 you can add or remove
the particular ciphers that you'd like
people to use to reach all those clients
if they are working from home and their
employees and hopefully they're in the
right country and they've got the right
roles are using good encryption in
transit that you trust and validate and
conforms to your standards so another
question that comes from this is okay so
we're running our service in more of a
remote access model we're using identity
or web proxy we're using cloud armor
we're allowing people to access without
this corporate network anymore so where
are they connecting from where does the
traffic go to and actually how do my
services interact with each other and
what are they doing so VPC flow logging
is typically how we get this information
out VPC flow logging you turn it on on a
per subnet basis and record for
different types of traffic we record
into V PC so any traffic within the
subnet in travpsu
or subnets assuming the logins turned on
traffic to and from Google services so
sending a request to bigquery and
getting responses and also internet
traffic so internet egress and ingress
between your applications and services
and all these logs out so before going
to stack driver logging and they're
pretty valuable so the quickest way to
get some insight into them is to feed
them out into bigquery as we talked
about earlier use aggregated log exports
for each of your projects set it up to
feed their logs out aggregate the logs
set up the filters to send just the VPC
flow logs out into bigquery so they're
immediately available to query I'm gonna
use data studio to build a nice little
report on top of it to try and figure
out what's in the logs so here's a
little dashboard that I pulled together
with a sample app
I span up I didn't put any country
restrictions on it I was just interested
to see who's gonna start pinging this
random hello world application and I
spun up so you can see here that it was
running in two regions we got Europe
West one in Europe West - we had
connections from a lot of different
countries we can see the round-trip time
for the packets that were coming through
there's a huge amount of detail and
information that's really valuable
inside this and these logs and typically
building this in non cloud environments
requires pretty expensive technology
fairly specialized vendors and dealing
with actually the volume of traffic it
can produce VPC flow logging can produce
a decent amount of information and you
can mine some really interesting trends
in it particularly when you're looking
across your projects and across your
applications looking for common types of
traffic looking for particular
applications that connecting to you that
you don't like looking for ticular ports
and protocols that you're not expecting
so then that leads to another use case
which services talk to each other so in
a world where things are very connected
there's lots of dependencies and around
it there's some great announcements at
next this week talking around sto so it
SEOs fantastic if you're running in a
micro services environment inside
kubernetes many of my customers are not
at that stage yet they're using
traditional virtual machines and
infrastructure and they're talking to
each other in all kinds of wonderful
ways and they just kind of hope they
know what they're doing so if we're
using VPC flow logging we turn on the
login for all the different subnets and
now we can start to profile the
applications and we can figure out which
ports and protocols are being used how
much traffic is being sent between them
and one of my customers took this even
further took the aggregated exports and
the summaries of those flows and then
turn them into VP C firewall rules and
applied them unlocked it down as a
policy so they monitored it for a period
of around two weeks they found every
single connection that they saw between
these applications and then build very
specific firewall walls to limit that
connectivity to only those particular
approved connections so what they found
was that when the application changed
and then they found a new connection was
coming through the question becomes is
it a developer can we correlate this
with an update or a patch the software
we were using okay fine we just need to
update the documentation and the release
process better to incorporate that
change or is it nefarious activity has
someone compromised our application and
now they're trying to move around and
see what other services are around they
could go and connect to answering that
question is pretty critical and this
gives you a lot of visibility to see
that very quickly and then do the
investigation so at a use case I saw
recently where the customer was how do I
keep my secrets secret and we may use
cloud kms for this and it's really
important to share you cannot store
secrets inside cloud kms but it's an
enabling technology that will help you
keep your secrets secret the use case
here was API keys so an application that
was being built talked to a third-party
service that authenticate with an API
key in this case it was sending emails
the development a test environment had
one key that had a limited quote or net
limit amount of spend production had
another key and they simply wanted to
make sure that that key wasn't
distributed widely they didn't want to
keep it inside the source coax and every
developer could access and they didn't
quite know where to put it so the
recommended solution for this and this
is on a public documentation is building
two projects to separate the duties and
actually this is three if you think
about the application that's running as
well so on the left-hand side we have
the secret storage project I'm going to
store them in Google Cloud Storage on
the right hand side we have the cloud
kms project which is the encryption and
decryption and the nice thing here is
that one person or one team can manage
the keys another person in another theme
can manage the encrypted secrets so the
first thing you do is you take your API
key you send it to cloud kms you pick
the particular key in keyring that you
want and it gives you the encrypted blob
to store you then place it in Google
Cloud storage in a bucket as the
encrypted blob when your application
starts up it does two things first it
connects to Google Cloud storage and
reads that blob from the bucket you off
see set up all the permissions and
scopes and roles to be able to pull that
down if any other person had access to
that bucket and logged in and saw it it
would be no use because they couldn't
actually see what's inside that
encrypted blob
so the next step is it goes to cloud KMS
it sends the encrypted blob and it
returns the decrypted version of it and
says here's your API key so what you've
done is you've delinked it you've bought
in separation of the duties someone can
independently rotate the keys and manage
the keys for you
another team commanding encrypted blobs
and secrets then the application can run
fairly stateless Li doesn't need to be
bundled with the secrets every time it
starts from restarts it goes and grabs
that key again and of course this is all
logged so you can start to look for
activity and say well was there any
failed decryption attempts was anyone
pulling down these particular keys from
a different application and a different
source that wasn't then going and
decrypting them you got some pretty good
visibility there so the final solution
I'm going to talk about which is a
really common question is are my
machines up to date and we're talking
about infrastructure here so we're
talking about plain old virtual machines
and the assumption is that they need
updating they need patching and also
they need to conform to your security
standards so there's the baseline that
you define the baseline might be a NIST
or a C is standard and probably your
organization's specific requirements as
well but let's say there's been some
particular vulnerability occur and you
want to update G Lib C or live SSL and
make sure it's maintained so there's two
questions really how do you make sure
people are only using trusted images and
secondly how do you make sure they're
always using the latest version so the
first thing we're going to do is going
to build custom images so part of
compute engine includes an image
registry it's not actually called an
image registry but it is an image
registry inside of compute engine and
with this you can store baked images
typically it's an automated process that
we'll go through and pull down the
patches build them together do your
security configurations and hardening
and publish it could also be a manual
process as well depending on volume and
you can choose whatever flavor you like
particular versions of Linux or Windows
or whatever takes your fancy
and publish those custom images share
them and make them available for other
users and other projects to start with
so in this case a user that has access
to start a virtual machine an instance
pulls the image from the
his registry based on the URL and then
builds it from that version there's a
constraint you can apply in resource
manager that allows you to control which
particular versions and which particular
images can we use and this is important
because by default Google publish a
whole range of images for you we produce
standard Ubuntu standard CentOS standard
Windows Server and that doesn't conform
to your security standards and policies
its passion it's updated and it's fairly
up-to-date with all the vulnerabilities
but it pro doesn't contain your
particular configurations and your
endpoint tools and management tools so
you can apply this constraint and
essentially say none of my users can use
any of the Google provided and libraries
they can use none of the Google product
images is completely denied so what
they're left with is that can only
access the custom versions which you've
published so then what you're saying is
that any developer any person anywhere
in your organization that wants to spin
up an instance has to use an instance
that comes from our custom images which
we've approved and we standardized and
we've pushed out so images go through a
life cycle there's four different states
that they go through by default they're
active you create a new image people can
use it a few days after that you can
deprecated it and you can say that it's
allowed to be used and often people will
support two or three old versions but
they'll get a warning saying that this
is not the latest version and typically
people access images based on the name
or the family they'll say just give me
the latest version of Ubuntu rather than
the particular version that's been
produced but this will tell them
actually the version you just specified
if they've hard-coded in a version
that's not okay obsolete will actually
stop them using it so if they try and
start an instance using that particular
image that's now obsolete it will fail
it won't start up and it will give them
a failure instead of a warning and then
the fourth state is deleted where the
image is flagged as deleted it's not
actually removed from disk you have to
do that separately but it's no longer
visible and available so you can do
automated obsolescence so what this
means is that when you tell image to be
a version of an image to be deprecated
there's two extra flags you can pass
there's an obsolete in and there's a
delete in and this can be a relative
amount of time so in seven days or an
absolute amount of time a particular
date that you give it so as part of your
processes I deal in an automated baking
process you can say right here's the
latest version of an image I've just
published for you and the previous
version deprecated it today so all my
users will get warnings telling them
this is in the latest version and
automatically will then make it obsolete
in seven days time or delete it in 14
days time it's another thing you don't
have to think about it'll just run
through that lifecycle for you and users
should treat it appropriately if people
start complaining that the version of
the image isn't available they need to
change their deployment scripts to use
the image family rather than particular
versions so we talked about three
different things here we talked about
control identity is super important in
any cloud provider particularly google
cloud because all of your access to
resources is focused around your
identity there's much less of a focus on
network controls particularly with more
of the managed services service accounts
are really powerful if you use them
correctly and actually there's lots of
little details around who can access
that service account that's definitely
something I'd recommend you go away and
review probably with full saty
to see who has that control visibility
is out there you can see everything that
happens into our Google cloud but not by
default and you can't wait until there's
an incident to go and find that because
unless the logs are on you can't go
backwards and see it so you need to
review data access logging you need to
review VPC file or logging and if it's
appropriate turn that on today to
prepare you for the future and we talked
a bit about some solutions how do we
combine different DCP services together
to get you to a point that you can run
your applications and services more
securely and get you prepared for a
beyond court world of the future where
all your employees can access remotely
securely and do whatever they need to
thank you very much for attending my
talk I'll be available to take questions
outside
[Applause]
[Music]